there's just like this
confused
lie infested
rat hole and out of that comes the
democrats comes the mainstream media and
everything else and then of course comes
the cultural part of this it leaks into
what gets on television who your
comedians are etc etc
and what they have to do always is not
just lie about everything and tell you
they're protecting life while they're
killing life but they often they also
have to scare the hell out of you they
have to make sure that you know that
you're a racist and a bigot and an evil
person and that they're literally going
to come to the restaurants where you eat
i can't describe how painful it is to be
here now in a place where the supreme
court has the power to erase 50 years of
constitutional law make no mistake this
is not where it ends conservatives will
not rest until they have come for all of
our rights everything we have fought for
could be lost unless we take it back
it's not just about voting in november
it's about doing everything in our power
to protect and help vulnerable people
access abortion across state lines and
we have to raise hell in our cities in
washington in every restaurant just as
elito eats at for the rest of his life
because if republicans have made our
lives hell it's time to return the favor
so that is samantha bee she was formerly
of the daily show
i think she has a show on tbs or comedy
central or something i'm not sure where
she's doing that show from nobody is
watching any of these shows that's just
how it is oh i guess she her show now
moved to hbo max or something i mean
that's one of the things that happens
with these people if you just give the
system what it wants if you're sort of
like a brian stelter type you just
repeat all the talking points of the
system the system will just keep
rewarding you even if nobody's watching
any of your shows it'll just keep giving
you more and more money and then your
shows will be canceled speaking of the
daily show jon stewart what happened he
leaves the daily show
and then he gets this i think apple tv
show right where they paid him probably
10 million dollars a year he goes full
woke and then they get rid of him it's
like you're you're a useful tool to the
system you're just you're banta fodder
how about that i haven't done a star
wars reference in a while uh that's what
you are you freaks anyway uh what she's
saying there and i don't know that
anyone's watching her show she also has
probably 20 writers on that show uh i
got these three fools in here no offense
guys but you know what i'm saying that
was that was a little offensive great
people but you know what i mean you know
you're not hollywood trained writers
that's all i'm saying thank god i'd fire
you if you were anyway what she's saying
there is
that you should follow samuel alito to
where he eats that here is a man who did
his job first off she's also saying that
they've erased 50 years
of law and it's like no they made a
decision in 1973 that the justices now
decided was not constitutional so the
justice this was the problem with roe v
wade in the first place in 1973 when the
justices looked at it they said oh there
is a constitutional right to an abortion
except it's not in the constitution
again there are things that are actually
in the constitution there are things
that are in the bill of rights that are
actually codified that's a new word
everyone's using right now codified into
law if they were making decisions that
were in conflict with written law then
we'd have a real problem on our hands
but they looked at it they said wait a
minute abortion the right to an abortion
is not in the constitution thus
we must give it back to the states
because things that are not in the
constitution should be given back to the
states that's what federalism is that's
the basic point of the whole freaking
system that's how it is supposed to work
so the system is working right now but
they don't want the system to work
because they want to own you they want
one as i keep saying they want one ring
to control them all they want one power
to control everybody so someone like
samantha b not only is she lying she
either is lying i don't believe she
doesn't know what she's talking about so
she's blatantly lying she's obviously
not funny i don't know who's watching
any of that stuff but she's also ramping
up and this is what they want and
they've been doing it for a long time
ramping up that you should get in their
faces remember maxine waters don't let
them have any peace aoc this is what
ilhan omar does this is what democrats
do all the time they're allowed to
overtake federal buildings go see what's
going on in wisconsin they're allowed to
burn down cities go to any blue state
they're allowed to do all of these
things but when they do it it's somehow
thought of as nice and it's nice and
pleasant destruction when they destroy
the nail salon
by the korean immigrant
they're doing it in the name of black
lives matter they're better than you
that's what they are